el cob il 19 se ensaña con italia
el país supere los 40 mil contagios en
un solo día por primera vez y registró
550 muertes índice más alto desde abril
ante el aumento de contagios el gobierno
agregó a las zonas rojas en las regiones
de toscana y campaña en su capital
nápoles los hospitales enfrentan una
fuerte presión se la curva
en este momento si la curva de contagio
sigue así el número de pacientes se
saldrá de control así que estamos
sujetos a un gran estrés trabajando sin
pausa sin mirar los horarios la variada
obra de agentes en santa irrupción en la
guardia mapeo en el banco del cartel y
no un panorama similar vive francia con
más de 32 mil hospitalizaciones una
cifra superior al pico alcanzado en
abril aunque el ritmo de contagios e
ingresos se ha desacelerado y los
médicos confían en las experiencias
previas estábamos un poco en terreno
desconocido en la primera ola como todos
ejecutamos las acciones mecánicamente
pero ahora estamos mucho más tranquilos
nos tomamos más tiempo con lo que
hacemos ahora lo conocemos es un poco
más simple para nosotros hoy a
diferencia de muchos países europeos
rusia ha evitado retomar el
confinamiento pese a registrar otra vez
un récord diario de contagios con 21 mil
983 en moscú comenzó a regir un cierre
nocturno para bares clubes y
restaurantes por dos meses medida que
preocupa el sector
[Música]
como trabajadora y gerente de un bar me
opongo a la medida
somos un bar después de todo la mayoría
de los bares funcionan de noche no
entiendo del todas las medidas tomadas
pese a la difícil situación el ritmo de
contagios en europa parece ralentizarse
según la o ms la región sumó 239 mil
positivos en las últimas 24 horas una
cifra menor a los más de 300 mil
contabilizados en jornadas anteriores